comprehensive dental care the sponsors
of this segment are dedicated to helping
you achieve the smile aesthetic you've
always wanted here's how they do it
it's estimated that over 175 million
americans have at least one missing
tooth so comprehensive dental care is
here to educate that population on their
best options my practice is focused
mainly on dental implants and
single tooth
restorations and full arch
replacement of teeth
i've been doing dental implants for 25
years in other words dr hendrickson
knows what he's doing he's also one of
the national full arch restoration
trainers for highbridge dental lab which
helps his practice focus on comfort
aesthetics and function
let's talk aesthetics the beauty of the
high bridge is that it's supported
typically
with six implants in the upper jaw
and five implants in the lower jaw which
allows us to make a
basically a bridge
that includes 12 teeth it gives a
patient a full complement of smile and
how does dr hendrickson go about
designing your hybrid smile we take a
lot of photographs we
we stand in front of the patient we
watch them talk this is why the full
arch restoration is a better option than
single implants i had one lady a number
of years ago that came in she had 15
single implants done
over the past 20 years
as one tooth would break
they'd take it out put an implant in
the gum tissue melt away another tooth
would break
she would
even though she had all of her teeth for
the most part she continued to have
problems hybridge allows that finished
look while staying authentic to your
look we have multiple shades to look at
look for
we go through we can go through a very
tedious long process of trying these in
to make sure they're absolutely perfect
they want this one tooth just rotated
just ever so slightly we can do that and
your new smile will stand the test of
time they don't absorb stain
they're easy to care for which is really
another cool thing when we're talking
about
the hygienics of this okay people want
to be able to keep these clean right
hybridge is designed to be hygienic we
go over
how to care for these with the patient
they don't have to ever come out of the
mouth to be cleaned these are made so
that they just
they they touch the gum tissue they're
easily you can floss underneath them
we use water pick we show you how to
cleanse them according to dr hendrickson
the process of putting the hybrid in is
also relatively pain free patients
typically say the first 18 hours are the
worst with some soreness the next day
when we put these in the patient's
mouths
they look 10 years younger
you know if you look at somebody's face
and eyes
that has dental problems
um it may sound cliche but sometimes
they kind of come in kind of lifeless
because they
they're not they don't like their smile
they're not happy with it so they're not
smiling
and when we can give them that smile
back their whole face lights up
thank you comprehensive dental care for
sponsoring this segment they're located
in henderson for more information call
702-735-3284
we will be right back